[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual fall
chess classic you are looking live in
the beautiful and historic Central West
End in st. Louis Missouri just a hop and
a skip from Forest Park the jewel of st.
Louis and what a location for this event
so come on down two floors below and
welcome into Studio B hello chess fans
Bensimon and international master Eric
Rosen here for the call day 5 of the
Fall Classic right we're more than
halfway through the event and I think
the players might be getting a little
bit tired I'm feeling the the tiredness
a little bit but I'm ready for hopefully
several more rounds of fighting Jess
let's see where we stand right now in
group a our masters division okay so we
have two players at the top alexei
gribov and alexander lunderman
and the rest it's some real big log jam
right there and you see Darla it's
bringing up the rear but still in this
event I would say it's anybody's chess
tournament and now here are the
standings for Group B the challengers if
you will and you know typically in these
events we see one person from one of the
fields begin to emerge around this time
and right now it is the Armenian
champion from 2017 of Hannah's got boos
young three and a half points he has a
full one point cushion against his
nearest rivals and we'll see if he can
capitalize even further today on this
one let's glance at the tournament
format in case you're joining us for the
very first time this is a round robin
affair the time control is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves and then there's
30 minutes added on for the remainder of
the game there is a 30 second increment
from move number one and to encourage
fighting chess there are no agreed draws
allowed of for the thirtieth move
black okay let's take a look at the
schedule once again we are it round
number five of nine everyday the games
begin at us chess champs calm at 1:00
p.m. Central Time our broadcast begins
two and a half hours after that at 3:30
Central Time
and please note that on Thursday we are
beginning universally early so we can
have room for playoffs if necessary also
room for the final dinner - from I heard
there's a closing dinner the night the
tournament ends so sure the players will
look forward to that yes that's the
thing we're all looking forward to to be
quite honest you never know what you're
gonna get but it's really good alright
and all along the way we want you to
join us on YouTube
if you're not there already on Twitch if
you want to go there on us chest champs
calm tech check out the chests 24 module
all along the way we have a nice little
video player in the upper right a nice
chat room it's a lot of fun analysis you
can turn it on or off check it out
that's the best way to follow these
games all along the way and all over
social media we invite you to use the
hashtag fall chess classic we want to
make it more active come on guys join
this conversation we'll talk about it on
the air whatever you post as long as
it's appropriate and youtube chat room
I've got it up right now
I'm looking at your chats I'm looking at
your questions we will be addressing
those during this show so keep it so
civil and keep it thoughtful and now
without wasting any more time here are
the pairings right now in group a all of
the games are still in progress daro
spirits vs. Eric Hanson your riku's ABAB
versus yoon Ludvig hammer Rae Robson vs.
cerumen Alec Slenderman vs. Lazaro burrs
own and what is our key matchup today
err yeah we have version of Cobian
against Alexey drei of two heavy hitters
in Group A pretty much they're both
legends and in some sense given that
they're part of the older pack of of the
group and we had a co bein in the studio
yesterday after a very solid draw he
seemed pretty calm and relaxed and
collected and I do want to take a glance
at their current position because things
are looking very symmetrical a little
bit boring if we go back and just see
the opening a Cobian played one of his
trademark lines that exchange slot
variation which if I'm not mistaken
Akopian taught kids class about a couple
weeks ago where he showed this line to
group of kids at the st. Louis chess
club and I'm wondering if perhaps tray
of watched that video and maybe expected
this line the thing about this variation
is that Weitz has a very slight
advantage because white gets the first
move and in symmetrical positions
usually white can fight for something
but it seemed like Draya was quite well
prepared and I like the idea that dre of
employees in this position after Bishop
to e7 the idea was to play Knight h5 to
grab the bishop pair this prompted the
Cobian to play h3 giving some escape
squirt for the bishop
but then after this move Bishop to d6
seems a bit weird that Trey have moved
his bishop
two times in a row so early on in the
game but now white white is forced to
trade off this bishop and cannot play a
move like Bishop g3 given that the pawn
is not not supporting it from h2 and
from this position both sides just
complete the developments nothing too
exciting happened a Cobian did have a
slight Pole because he did have a good
Bishop against the bad bishop but very
soon trade started happening around move
18 tonight's came off the board and then
rooks came off the board and then more
Brooks came off the board and then
eventually Queens came off the board and
it seems like both players are just
trying to get to move 30 and then I'm
expecting to see just a draw in three
more moves
is it is it precisely drawn do you think
I mean is there any is there any chance
to for one player to break through or do
you see it as a draw I mean if we had to
put an evaluation on the current
position why it is perhaps still a
little bit better but I doubt that a
coal game will be playing for much here
at last position is just so solid white
still has a more active Bishop some
slight space advantage on the Kings side
but there's no real targets to attack I
mean black has everything under control
just a couple pawn islands and black is
just ready to prop centralize a king and
then probably just wait and I don't see
how a Cobian can make any progress
without weakening himself now this is a
type of position maybe if you turn on
the engine it will say maybe plus 0.2
plus 0.3 given that engine will like
white spattered Bishop and likes more
space in the Kings side but I don't
think it's anything to play for all
right well we expect a drawing up here
in our key matchup in Group A but let's
glance over at Group B and what's going
on in our challengers division we have
Stevens Eric versus Sergei as a Rob I
pardon me Ashwin Jha rhombuses Chris u L
Shawn more ADEA body versus action
Chandra Danish poros taking on Brandon
Jacobsen and our key matchup that's
right we have Konrad Holtz against LaVon
Hayes caboose Ian who has really been
impressing us this tournament kuboos Ian
winning his first three out of the four
games drawing one game putting him in
clear lead with three and a half out of
four I'm sure he's looking to continue
the momentum especially after yesterday
he received a very generous gift by
Dennis Boros after Dennis just blundered
upon and googoos Ian took the game home
for a full points let's take a look at
their current situation go Busey and was
playing very quickly out of the opening
and this is position a position from
just about 10 to 20 minutes ago where
the pawn structure isn't as pretty as
the game that we just saw between a code
andraia of there's very much damage
damage pawn structure for both sides
white having double isolated pawns in a
file isolate pawn on h3 and on d4
meanwhile black also has a few isolated
pawns on the Queen side double pawns in
the Kings side now we should mention
that white is up a pawn but with so many
pawn weaknesses I think black has some
nice compensation here and I do like the
move that go Busey and played in this
position simply pawn to a5
very nice pawn break this is a very
thematic move that you'll see in many
different opening mill game or endgame
scenarios whenever White has this pawn
structure with a 3 and B 4 it makes
sense to try and break down the
structure with a pawn break in this case
the a pawn that being supported by the
rook and the bishop applying pressure
far away from f8 and it looks like this
is an attempt to just break down White's
queenside pawns after Bishop to d2 the
pawns get traded
then the bishops get traded and now
every single pawn in this position is an
isolated pawn for whites however it
seemed like things continue to simplify
after Knight d5 nice outpost square
attacking before pressuring f4 white
plate King to g3 black wins would be for
pawn rook c4 Knight jumps into d3 and
then okay so I'm dancing around a little
bit let's get to the current position
where after rook takes you six White is
still up upon but it seems very
difficult for for white to make any
progress still given that White's pawns
are just pretty weak and I mean there is
a passed pawn on h3 but it seems like
black has everything under control here
and I do like this pawn chain by black
even though there are double F pawns
blacks pawns support one another and it
seems like this position it should be a
draw relatively soon now I am impressed
with caboose Ian's time management given
that he has 90 minutes on the clock they
they just reached move 40
so there's probably not going to be any
time trouble in this game I mean if one
player was to win they have to attack
well I guess I guess if I were to win
this I have to attack the f7 pawn right
and get that off the board but it's if
you defend it it's fine yeah I think
black is just gonna probably bring the
king tactics and then probably just
waits maybe poke and prod at White's
given that the rook can drop swing
around and activate itself from far away
maybe a four or a three to tickle some
of these these white pawns but that
seems like there's not much to play for
for either side so it's possible we'll
see a few quick draws relatively early
in the round okay so now that we have
glanced at our key matchups let's take a
look at what is on the line for these
players in this event first in Group A
there is a $22,000 prize fund where the
champion will win six grand of that pot
and now Group B $14,000 prize fund and
the champion walks away with $4,000 one
of the games well did you have a game in
mind before I suggest won it Eric uh I
do actually okay what would he I would
like to hop to the game between the
youngest player in the field Christopher
you playing
Ashwin Jayram who has been has been
recovering from it earlier lost in the
tournament and is now maybe building up
some momentum after his nice win
yesterday against Andra looks like they
have a very hard-fought battle given
that okay it seems like chaos in the
physician black is very overextended
with these pawns on e4 and d4 but both
are pretty well supported the e pawn
being supported by the Queen and the
bishop and upon being supported by the
Knights and the rook and I would feel a
bit uncomfortable as white given that
these pawns are so far pushed in the
position now many more moves have been
played from this position Christopher
did take on d4 and then played Queen to
g6
looks like Bach is just going for a very
strong King side attack
given that g2 is a very juicy target in
the position we can imagine that black
is having ideas maybe f3 or maybe even
III to unleash the Bishop from b7 so I
really like this move Queen to g6 this
prompted Ashwin to play Bishop to d5
perhaps trying to neutralize this Bishop
on b7 and after bishops get traded black
brings us Knights to f6
seems like Bach is just bringing more
and more pieces to the Kings side we see
most of the black pieces on the Kings
side I like the coordination of the
Knights they do defend each other and
this knight on f6 attacks the Queen
defends upon on e4 after Queen to c6
rook shiites threatening mates on g2 and
we should know this there's not too many
ways for white to defend in this
position the Queen is shut out on c6
given that this pawn is is defended on
e4 by the Knights so it seemed like
there's only one reasonable move for
white to play in this position - to
defend that move being g3 which is very
ugly move given that it looks quite
weakening and it kind of interferes with
this bishop on h4 but perhaps it it
keeps things under control and okay we
have even more chaos after Christopher
pushing even further with pawn to e3 and
then Ashwin took on e3 and Christopher
takes on g3 I like the sequence
sometimes when you push pawns it's with
the intention to simply undermine your
opponent's pawn structure and that's
what we're seeing here
white having kind of a mini pawn chain
on F 2 and G 3 Christopher attacks the
base of the pollen chain and then
completely destabilizes this g3 pawn and
now it's a question what to do as whites
seems like blacks attack is crashing
through
I would be terrified if I were Ashwin
though maybe his opponent doesn't look
like the most intimidating person to sit
across from you but if we look at the
position it just looks very terrifying
and you know this is a rated event so if
you have a loss to Brandon Jacobson or
Chris you you're gonna lose more points
it's true and you would to the other
players so you gotta stay on your game
and never you're never playing the
opponent you're playing the position
right that's very true
one of the games that really is looking
interesting it's very crowded a lot
happening on the board group a daro
spirits versus Eric Hanson let's check
that one out yeah this game actually
caught my eye
earlier we Lancer the position we can
really admire White's likes very nice
space advantage I want to go back and
look at the opening because dar was
actually unleashed woman I favor the
openings the London opening played after
Bishop to f4 and now Eric seemed to try
and go for a Kings Indian attack and
then Dora actually play the move here
that I would like to play Knight to c3
this is going into what we call the
Barry attack where white is intending to
play E for right away so I flock were to
play Bishop g7 then like a play d4 and
perhaps go into more Pierce or modern
territory where white is very quickly
controlling the center and very often
going for moves like Queen d2 castling
queenside and then perhaps going for
some later attack on the Kings side so
we see rather than playing Bishop to g7
Hansen responded with pawn to d5
preventing pony for after calling me
three Bishop g7 white plays a very
aggressive move here this is a type of
move you usually don't see as early on
move 5 we see pawn h4 now this is a very
trademark move of the barre attack and
this is one of my favorite moves to play
favorite openings to play in in blitz
games and over over the port tournament
games simply because White has a very
direct
idea of playing pawn h5 now just to
demonstrate this if we imagine black
ignores this idea and castles in the
position what would be more than happy
to play h5 and if Knight take h5 rook
take Age 5
pawn to h5 Queen to h5 White has
sacrificed a rook for an item pawn it so
white is currently down material but if
you look at the position you have to
prefer White's very nice attack already
on the King side ideas at Bishop d3
neither three and castling queenside and
i believe if you turn on the engine in
this position engine will love light
giving an evaluation of somewhere around
plus 1.5 so for that reason Hansen did
not allow pawn the pawn to advance
further to h5 rather played h5 himself
and then played to developed in somewhat
quieter fashion after a night of three
Bishop g4 Queen d2 I do like this move
Queen d2 because a purpose is to get out
of the pin to prepare to Castle
queenside and also to improve the night
with 95 and what this prompted black to
do was taking on f3 which is actually
not a move that black likes to play
early on because it concedes the bishop
pair and it also opens up this file for
white to potentially attack later on on
the Kings side so going forward from
here I do want to zoom forward you see
both players complete development Hansen
playing the Ben Feingold move always
play King b1 safer place for the King a
six and now e4 and now we begin to see
the central expansion from White's after
a six white is enjoying a pretty nice
space advantage also enjoying the bishop
pair both bishops having a very clear
purpose in the position after ninety
seven just seemed like a passive
position for black for many of these
moves 9 8 7 not the most aesthetic
square for the Knights incredibly
incredibly passive prop perhaps kicking
the bishop on g5 so white played Bishop
2h
after Queen d6 now we see e5 and White
has a pawn structure which you don't
usually see in the King's Indian does
this remind you of any certain opening
that might might be related to the
structure it's French
yeah it's it's just something that you
would normally see in the advanced
French now normally in the advanced
French black is not supposed to fee in
calico this bishop on g7 in this case
the bishop is staring at the tip of
White's pawn chain so I really like the
way that the daro explaining this so far
after Queens e8 92 seems like white is
just bringing all of the pieces over to
the Kings side to help out in the attack
bishop take h6 queen take aged six now
the threat is a simple queen take h5
utilizing the pin on the g file so King
h8 was played now the knight Hopson to
f4 and white is just having a number of
of just crushing tactical ideas for
starters simple
I take age 5 because now that this pawn
is no longer pinned to the king but it's
pinned to the checkmating square on g7
given that if white could take on h5 and
open the G file there would be the pen
potential for Queen g7 mates not only
that but white is also threatening
Bishop take on e6 here given that if
pawn take back on e6 light could then
recapture with a knight threatening the
Queen and threatening Queen g7
checkmates this is one of the most
powerful forks in chests when you can
attack the Queen and attack amazing
threats so Hanson played probably what
is the only defensive move here rook to
g8 seems like white continues to improve
the position bringing the knight to a
very beautiful outpost square on c5 and
now Knight to g8 Queen afore Queen e7
and now Bishop F 1 I just want to take a
moment and
laughs at at blacks setup here I don't
usually see the chest bra playing like
this but this just reminds me of a
turtle just kind of tucked away and its
shell just praying for for dear life
that it's not going to be attacked and I
guess so far that the turtle strategy is
working where white doesn't have an
immediate breakthrough but I mean
Locke's position just looks so ugly this
rook has no moves
Knights have very difficult time
activating the only issue for white is
the time situation but I would much
rather be white in this position I mean
you got a look where these two players
are right now in the standings in this
event neither one of them can be too
happy about how they performed so far
Dara's sitting with just one point out
of four and erik hansen is at point 1/2
I believe so poor Eric it's tough I mean
if daro can win the game that will be a
nice kind of confidence booster for him
it's I know it's not easy to have kind
of a bad event where it seems like
everything is going in against you but
sometimes if you can have a nice win if
if daro can maximize his advantage and
convert the position maybe that will
give him some momentum in the later end
of the tournament in the meantime we do
have two results that have come in for
Group A one of which we we did expect a
cobia Andreyev have drawn their game
there's no surprise there another draw
from a game we did not look at Alexander
Lenderman versus vers own that was a
draw now if I'm not mistaken that means
that the two leaders Dre ov and
Lenderman have drawn their games maybe
that gives some chances for some of the
other players in Group A to catch up yes
it does actually uh so but Brazil okay
so at the leaderboard we have live live
leaderboard Lenderman Andreyev at the
top with three and a half and a cobia
member zone with two and a half and then
we have three players with two
points Zathura interesting love and
hammer so it seems like the the leaders
will stay puts right three and half
points
yeah there's opportunity there no doubt
who's above and hammer looks interesting
this is it looks like a game we should
check out in group a I see a very closed
position with major all major pieces on
the board with the addition of two dark
sweet bishops for each side let's go
back just a few moves see how the play
has been developing I mean going back to
right around this position I do like
white setup whenever you're playing a
game and there's only one open file in
the position one of the best strategies
and one of the most simple strategies is
to double your rooks on that file and we
can see that kuzava has done just that
in this position putting both rooks on
the only open file and black is now in a
situation where the file can't really be
contested and I could improve even
further here with a move like Queen to
see for having a triple battery also
what's known as an Alekhine's gun just a
very powerful weapon in the position so
I do like White's position around here
let's see how play developed after a six
white gains more space on the Queen side
with pawn to d5 maybe what white is
trying to do is pipe on e4 and then
Bishop a3 because this is a one downside
for whites in the current moment this
Bishop not doing too much on b2
especially when all your pawns are on
the same color as a bishop usually not a
good addition so I think white simply
wants to reposition the pawns on light
squares and then make the bishop a bit
happier
so after pawn d5 black plays rook a
seven Queens is he form achieving the
triple battery now we see pollen e6 pawn
to a4 a trade happened on b5 Queen a six
and now Queen b3 seems like White's and
full control black is very much
restricted even though white has not
only one work on the C file black can
still not contest the file and now
like has a lot of pressure auditioning
on this half-open V file
given that the rook on b5 and the Queen
on b3 deformer battery against the b7
pawn now the b7 pawn is defended and for
the time being but this is gonna be a
long term headache for luck to
constantly babysit the pawn on b7 also
black has to babysit the pawn on e6
given that the queen is applying nice
pressure in multiple directions so I do
like the way who's above is
demonstrating some nice kind of
positional pro-us
continually improving his position I can
imagine that very soon that will see
some move like Bishop to a3 simply to
improve the bishop and we might even see
Brooke to be one maybe shifting that
triple battery from the C file to the B
file just to pile down on this sweet
pawn on b7 in once that pawn goes then
that that eight pawn is a pasture for
white yeah that's certainly a long-term
strategy to someday when the b-pawn make
the a pawn past and then someday Queen
the 8th on all right yeah it looks very
good for coos above who is still in the
in the top portion of this event as far
as contention goes I should also mention
I am taking a look at the twitch chat
here and we do have a comment from Z jar
perhaps spotting some simple tactics
that I have been overlooking white
actually has a simple threat after Queen
b3 of playing rook b6
simply attacking the Queen and
threatening also the pawn on e6 so black
does need to defend in this position and
I think black play the only move to
defend with roof to d6 perhaps trying to
to not allow this this move to take
place and for the time being black is
still holding on but I mean white white
is certainly the one for choice in this
game over in Group B there is a rook
that is going up but I'm not sure if
it's over in the game between
zurk and Azeroth and I'm not sure what
the rook is doing but this looks really
interesting to me let's take a glance at
it yeah the last movie played rook to h5
I want to go back here they had a
variation of the Sicilian in which black
played this early kind of pawn h5 to
reinforce the knight on g4 after Bishop
to g4 hthe for at first glance it seems
like this pawn is undefended on g4 given
that Queen tech g4 does pick up the pawn
I think the problem with this would be
that black could then seize upon on e4
and now the problem for white is that
this knight is pinned on c3 to this chat
meetings where c2 so when I taking
forward would just run into Queen c2
mates so an interesting decision by
black to allow the pawn on g4 to just
kind of stay put being attacked by the
Queen but the queen is kind of tied down
here to covering both c2 and e4 so I do
like to move that search play rook H e1
putting more supports on pawn on e4
crops giving the Queen's some more
mobility now we see Knight to c4 seems
like Bach really wants to focus on the
Queen side in this position given that's
White's King is a long-term target after
Bishop to d4 Brooke h7 kind of a strange
move perhaps unpinning the Jeep on not
entirely sure what the purpose of this
is maybe wanting to play g6 and f5 but
okay one more move has been played for
each side Queen D 3 and then rook to h5
I guess it was just to to avoid the
surprise yes Queen d3 does align the
Queen with the rook and I'm realizing
here that black maybe doesn't want to
play g6 because this this could allow
some explosive pawn break in the center
and pawn to f5 to actually open up some
some files so vac does want to keep the
center closed with the King so on he
eights so Brooke h5 getting out of the
way
the Queen in a dream scenario Blackwood
maybe someday love to swing the rook all
the way across - how about attack on the
Queen side but yeah for the time being I
do kind of like the creativity by Sergei
Azhar of in this position given that
he's left his King in the center but but
his king is safe and his rook is not
only helping control the fifth-ranked
but maybe also discouraging whites from
from executing any sort of break on the
fifth rank and we could imagine that
black might want to continue very soon
with some pawn advances like pawn before
pawn 85 and just continue the pawn storm
so let me update the board there's been
one more move pawn to a3 perhaps trying
to discourage pawn d4 and this is the
current position I mean plenty three
it's a good sign for black that white
isn't doing anything immediate and now
it's a question how does black try and
continue with some attacking ideas given
that before no longer seems playable
maybe there's some possibility of
playing a5 and perhaps this is a
usefulness of the rook on h5 now that it
supports the b-pawn and if a5 is played
there's ideas of four black and playing
v4 or a4 so if I had to choose one side
I would probably pick black but both
players are getting bit low on time and
they still have 17 moves to make until
time control alright we'll have to keep
an eye on this one for sure
also in Group B we have a game between L
Shaun Medea body and st. Louis and
action Chandra there are passed pawns
one for each side in the middle of the
board looks like the Queen's might come
off here what's going on here Erik yeah
seems like a position which okay but
it's probably more of a mess earlier a
lot of things have been traded and if
I'm I'm just doing a basic material
counts black is currently up the
exchange
white does have the five pawns on the
board two three pawns so why does have
two pawns for being down in the exchange
after Queen to g7 perhaps
Oxshott is begging for a queen trade
given that white is in great attacking
shape given the king is a bit unsafe on
g8 and normally situations like this
where why it is kind of posed with the
question whether or not to trade Queens
you have to ask yourself about King
safety safety and I think in this
position we can see White's King is far
more safe and lacks King so I like the
decision that Alshon made here playing
Queen to c6 avoiding the Queen trade
keeping the tension also may be
preparing rook to g7 and this is a very
common attacking idea in in many endgame
situations where you want your rook to
come to the point in seventh rank and if
57 could be played then Y will be having
some fun and I do like the positioning
of this ninth on e3 just simply
blockading blacks only passed pawn
defending a lot of key squares on the
Kings side discouraging any apology for
break so it seems like wife has some
nice harmony in this position look at
the time he rocks at Chandra down to 30
seconds yeah I I know ox odd is somewhat
notorious for taking perhaps a little
too much time or earlier in the game
this happened yesterday to him against
Ashwin Jayram and the severe time
deficit just led to a blunder so he has
to play quickly here Queen f7 was played
I think this is a great situation for
Elle Shawn to be and I mean the opponent
so low on time they have seven more
moves to make until time control and
seems like White has the initiative it's
a question of how White's
can perhaps crash through with attack
there are some lines I'm calculating
here I mean the first move to look at is
the most aggressive move rook to d7
now this one allow black to play queen
f2 which looks a bit scary but after the
simple king h1 I don't think black would
be able to make much progress if the
knight were to be taken then there's
just a simple made into starting with
queen g6 followed by queen g7 mates so
I'm sure I'll Shawn is perhaps
considering this very ambitious rook
move into the heart of blacks position
it's just a matter of concrete
variations and sometimes when you have
the time advantage you want to just use
that time to calculate you want to
calculate all the forcing moves and not
just play not just play one move and
then start thinking but really dig deep
and perhaps if el Shawn can calculate
some forcing line he can whip it out
rather quickly and put auctions in a
situation where there's really no time
to calculate and for black he just has
to play on pure intuition el Shawn more
Thea body sitting right now at two
points in Group B I think there's a
piece that is being offered up as a
sacrifice over in Group A in the game
between Rey Robson and Seth Roman it
looks like Ray had a knight on the rim
and he's offering up offering it up to
Black's G pawn is that what's happening
here I'm just trying to digest what's
going on in this position at first I
thought face clocks at an hour and 29
minutes but it says one minute and 29
seconds which is not a lot of time to
make 15 more moves let's go back here
and see what is going on in black has
some nice play on the a file one thing
that catches my eye and see well how did
the rook come to a 1 Wow Knight to b3
well actually want to go back to this
position because it seems like this is
where the fireworks just started to come
after pawn to d4 Rey seemingly had a
very nice position given
the knight is attacked and white is
threatening this fork on d5 but this
move 93 highly creative taking advantage
of the fact that there is some pain
along the a file and the rook is now
attacked by the Knights if the rook were
to move there would be rook take a two
and black would be crashing through very
nice coordination with the rook the
knight the bishop supporting the knight
the queen supporting the rook so for
this reason ray decided to take on b3
going down the exchange but then having
d5 so we're gonna see some material
imbalance now that seems like ray did
win back a piece and now we have a very
classic material balance two minor
pieces for a rook
for a working a pawn actually if I'm
counting correctly normally situations
like this if it's a middle game scenario
two minor pieces are typically more
valuable than rook and pawn the black
does have some annoying pressure along
the a file after f3 some repositioning
pawns e5 a very interesting move trying
to to make use of this Queen Bishop
battery perhaps destabilize White's
like structure on the King side pawns to
get traded on d5 now Bishop to c5 rook
b8 a trade on a1 and now this is a
moment that were that you were
mentioning before a Knight f5 this just
seems like a a pure sacrifice not caring
about the pawn which can very easily
capture I'm wondering if Rey is playing
this out of desperation or if this is
just a well calculated or maybe just
intuitive attempt to really tear apart
blacks King side we can imagine if the
pawn takes on that five whites Queen can
come in and this King is feeling pretty
naked on g8 if the Queen were to take on
the c3 why just having some fun Queen g5
Chuck followed by something like Bishop
e7 and this is a very big problem for
black given that white has the only dark
square bishop on the board and cases
like this the dark squares are just very
very weak for black I think that six is
pretty much unstoppable there would be
some slight checks maybe queen d4 but
after King King g2 maybe it's still a
bit complicated given black could
perhaps check a few more times but I
would like very much like White's
chances in that variation and I feel
like 9.5 is a move that Sethuraman did
not see coming it's kind of a so-called
invisible move usually even strong
players don't look at moves where
players are putting their pieces where
pawns can simply capture them and if
black doesn't capture the Knights on f5
then the knight can very happily hop in
to e 7 or even h6 and the fact that
black is committed to playing pawn g6
really weakens a lot of the dark squares
around the Kings side so even though Rey
is pretty low on time I do like his
chances here and given that Sethuraman
has been taking a while on this move
I'm sure ray is is thinking on his
opponent's time too to calculate what's
going to happen next big news in Group E
in the game between the Hungarian and
the American Danish Burroughs vs.
Brandon Jacobsen it looks like Boris is
losing a queen probably the game here
imminently
let's take a look it's the wrong game
let me go further down I don't think
we've talked about this game yet but I
was taking a look at it earlier and
seems like blacks attack was quite
menacing let's go back it just seems
like so much chaos every which direction
yeah actually before the broadcast
started I was looking at this position
trying to comprehend what was going on
after black's pawn emerged on d5 Boros
decided to cap
upon 85 which looks like a free pawn
though Jacobson had a very nice response
here
Bishop take h3 discovered attack against
a bishop on e5 also an attack against
the rook on f1 and okay after King take
h3 White's King became very unsafe on
the edge of the board I want to go back
and just illustrate one points that if
Bishop takes f6 black could take back
simply with the Queen and even though
this Bishop is still undefended on h3
this Bishop on f3 is also undefended so
white didn't probably not want to enter
this line so King take h3 was played
Brooke taking five pawn d4 and I like
the energetic play by black rather than
retreating the rook Jacobsen starts with
a counter-attack Queen d7 check King h2
and then very surprising exchange
sacrifice rook at a key for not the move
that I would first consider but I really
like the nature of this move because
after Bishop taking for Knight they're
planting a shake on it they said yeah
yep there we go maybe we have to get
Brandon in this video to take us through
this game can ice agree 100% feed a
master are now International Master
Brandon Jacobson who is looking to
perform very well in this tournament
this is all there's eight grandmasters
in this field I mean he was second place
going into this round and with the win
in this game I think he's going to be
props on the verge of catching up to
good news Ian or at least on pace for a
GM norm
yes he's undefeated across the three
draws and a win well now this makes had
two victories so good job Brandon
Jacobson yeah we'll have him in here
I'll probably hold off on going through
the the finale to the attack right
viewers will have to stick around for
for his his words on how the game
finished
so any any games to look at any more
interesting positions or and hammer in
group a let's go back to that one yeah
we were taking a look at this game
earlier and I was really admiring
White's position seems like white has
has been making progress since we last
saw it's just going back after rookie
six was played defending against this
threat of rookie six the white white
enter his box territory rook see a Czech
teen aged seven and now very explosive
move pawn to d5 earlier I was thinking
the bishop could activate activated
south via a 3 but pawn d5 very nice just
kind of pawn break to to try and tear
apart blacks position now there's a bit
of chaos because not only are the bishop
staring at each other but the pawns are
staring at each other and I could
imagine situation where if black takes
on d5 white can simply take back and now
f5 is a target the rook on f7 is also a
target it's just an undefended piece so
if black words are take well I could
just take back even though the spaceship
is undefended on b7 black has to run b2
rather black has to deal with the media
threat of Queen take f7 d5 nice move
this is a type of move that sometimes
you want to look for when your position
is really good and when your pieces are
good you want to look for the pawn
breaks to open up the position and
create these tactical scenarios that
will I will hopefully work in your favor
now hammer does have some time to fathom
what to do here just under 12 minutes on
the clock
Cruz above having just over five minutes
let me update the board this looks to be
the current position so we'll have to
keep an eye on this can see both players
are very focused hammer not having the
best event so far even though he had a
very beautiful game earlier in the vent
but it seems like who's above has been
just uh a solid players so far this
event do you think that hammer should
capture on d5 right now I mean what else
to do white uh white wants to take on e6
so if I move like Bishop take b2 is
played maybe the only other candidate
move white doesn't necessarily have to
take back right away
y can play the the in-between move pawn
to e6 with a simple counter-attack
against the rook if the rook were to
move then white takes back on me too and
all of a sudden there's mating threats
against this h8 square
maybe not made immediately but just
incredibly strong threats which is
nearly impossible to stop Black has no
way to stop the Queen phone from
infiltrating along this diagonal so I
think you're right that hammer probably
does have to capture on d5 though it is
a question does he capture with the pond
or the rook if rip take t5 or pawn to d5
black will be left in a scenario where
this light square diagonal will be
opening up and this work on f7 is just a
problem piece very well imagine a
scenario like like this one where white
is just crashing through this Queen on
a6 completely out of play like having
all the fun we could see hammer go go
down pretty hard in this game yes we
could no doubt about it yeah let's keep
an eye on that but in the interim Ashwin
Jha ROM and Chris you let's check back
in on those two in Group B
Chris you the loan feed a master now in
this field he has hidden earn an
International Master norm with four
points and that would be his that would
be his final norm
I believe so he would final norm he has
the ratings so he's he's like one good
tournament performance away from getting
the ion title and seems like he's going
all out against Jayram in this position
on all of the black pieces focused on
attacking on the kingside now sometimes
the problem when you're attacking on the
kingside but your own king is also on
the Kings side you could leave yourself
a bit overextended and I think that's
perhaps what we're seeing in this
position blacks King not having the best
shelter on h8 now black would love to
someday perhaps remove the knight from
Essex and unleash these this rook
battery along the F file the problem is
that black has to be constantly
concerned about this potential weakness
on each six now it is all right Brandon
Jacobsen ready to come into the studio
so we're gonna prep him and let's keep
looking at this game right all right and
all sounds good I was imagining that
black might want to play a move like
Knight g4 simply to bring the knight
into the attack even further at defend
the H pawn unleash the rooks now it is
Ashwin's move in this position the
question is what to do his pieces don't
seem that well coordinated especially
this rook on a1 the knight on f1 the
Queen on c6 it doesn't seem to be that
great coordination no I do like the the
setup or the configuration of this
Bishop and the rook kind of staring down
at this Knight but Ashwin has a lot of
time here 12 minutes just over 12
minutes to a minute and 33 seconds for
the youngster they are unmoved 32 there
are 8 more moves to play until time
control I'm sure Ashwin will be trying
to navigate his way through the chaos
in this position and attempting to to
just hold on for dear life given that
blacks attack is looking very scary
I'm also imagining threats of Queenie to
perhaps just infiltrating with the Queen
maybe a move to consider here for white
is to play rook a to this rook would
really like to enter back into the game
maybe not back into the game there's
enter the game from being very out of
the play on a1 and if the rook can swing
over to f2 then there can be so much
pressure against this knight on f6 so
it's possible we'll see a situation
where both players are trying to attack
on the Kings side and these situations
are are always exciting for us viewers
and us commentators to watch now we'll
keep an eye on this game but I do want
to welcome a special guest in the studio
Brandon Jacobsen congratulations after
winning winning your game today in
pretty stellar fashion so I would like
to get your thoughts on the game and
also your thoughts in the tournament
given that you're one of the youngest
players in the field second youngest to
Christopher you you're in high school
and do you have to kind of balance
schoolwork while playing this events
well I'm actually taking college classes
oh wow okay so okay it's very nice to
play myself gotcha
I've been there before as a college
student we're trying to balance college
classes and and chess and sometimes that
College classes are using easier to
balance because you have a bit more
flexibility so let's go through the game
now I also want to mention you recently
got your eye on title congratulations on
that do you have any grandmaster norms
yeah so is the grip the potential
Grandmaster norm in this event on your
mind or are you just trying to think
about well I don't think about it but
it's kind of art an environment like
this is very truly the best I can
well I won't make any attempts to try
and make you think about it further but
let's go back and and
now you you took down pretty form a
little player Dennis Poros with the
black pieces were you expecting an
English opening and how much of the
opening was pregame preparation fifty to
look at g5i play very similar lines as Y
in and usually I like to put the bishop
on and then defy or g5 and then combine
that with Knights side luck will take on
c3 and then go h6 take on c3 and then
play age six AHA and then take take 92
pretty equal ish yeah seems like a very
simple English position but I mean if
you can equalize from from this line and
sure you'd be you'd be fine with that
so Bishop d2 yeah seems a little bit
more passive but maybe trying to avoid
these potential double pawns on the
Queen side I do like the move that you
played here at a five right so if you if
he plays a three you would play Bishop
c5 makes a lot of sense so in the game
he played h3 and at what point did you
feel like the momentum was starting to
go in your seat around here I think
ephors little too ambitious get me up to
d4 square X I think his attack is too
slow I was considering 97 here but that
seems a little artificial like Betty of
95 and f5
giving up the bishop I see
but then I was a free white might
eventually get in d4 and if we can get
the bishop on before and play d4 it
should be slightly better for a white so
something like 83 so 83 they should take
this okay now I want to go a four here
but then I think white goes d4 no in a
slight advantage
mm-hmm so if Knight c5 instead
then I think p3 and now if I try that
five for example I'm very sure I can
just take on f5 and then go D for feel
like this is a risk with conceiving the
bishop here so early is if I can manage
to open up the position the bishops can
just be more Dominator c5 seen where
principal just trying to go 94 yeah seem
like a very logical decision given that
yeah you for looks a little bit ugly or
bucks the bishop and just permanently
weakens the d4 square now going forward
I I really liked what you did coming up
here after this move yeah I think I'm
already better here that's right if you
do anything active
and like you kind of built up just a
very solid position then you had this
very nice expanding move climbed e5 yeah
I could fish up c7 if I want to play it
safer for them it's not clear round
better if something like Bishop g2 d5
maybe even c5 here
I sort of like reversed for Lopez but
that's true seems like a slightly slower
game yeah I feel like d5 was very timely
though given that White's pieces work
bit out of the play especially this
Bishop on f3 and the palm and h3 being
targets and many of the tasks all
variations
after pawn on d5 the trade happens
and yes I'm like white didn't have too
many options here probably you shouldn't
take the pawn but it's already difficult
like I should you too maybe mm-hmm but I
can do something like take c4 c4 and
then Bishop c4
it seems like lack is having a lot of
fun yet again with this pawn on e4 in
Bishop on g2 it's slightly sad for
whites so yes seem like the position
just deflate c4 from when I went to d5 I
was calculating D takes me four here
after Bishop takes e5 would take you for
the idea is if he takes back D takes e4
Queen takes do you want whichever one he
takes back I played it should be three
or Bishop e2 so here I have bishop a -
mm-hmm potassium is rugby take stealing
I said it like that takes Bishop b3
Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes t1 takes he
can try for some compensation or a61
takes Kim G - a black should be better
here
but there are still it's so tricky like
tonight go to c3 and d5 it's a little
bit unclear but what should be better
yeah it looks looks preferable for black
but especially with this Knight coming
to d5 and also lots of call your bishops
maybe you you wouldn't have most winning
chances the reach I didn't go into this
was after go back instead of yeah
instead of D takes e4 Bishop takes f6
mm-hmm Queen takes f6 it's after do you
take C for do you take
sorry do you take me for Michigan says
yeah great takes bishop takes e4 and
then rotate it to here it looks nice for
black but there's no clear threat so if
somebody just like rook c1 come idea is
instead of rook c1 if he plays like rook
a1 then I think I can go
I should be through here so if we take
the rook is hanging and to defend the
net you have to go Queenie to Queenie 1
sorry 1 and then Bishop takes f2 here Oh
so they won record saying several takes
a 2 it should take c1 breath takes f6
and then Bishop takes a 2 and then this
seems like such a nice but then it
should be better for a black uh-huh but
the main problem was after a rogue a -
I'm not really threatening anything it
looks dangerous so I should have
initiative here - but I think what I did
was more clear mm-hmm yeah this is a
tricky position to evaluate because
white does have extra pawn and if you
don't have anything immediate and maybe
White's okay yeah so yeah I like what
you did in the game bishop take h3 he
seems just a lot more direct and we
actually didn't get to see the the
finale of this game in the broadcast
because you you finished so quickly so
that's already getting pretty long right
I didn't want to ask about this moment
though because we saw around rook to e4
was this was this a more intuitive
sacrifice I barely Kappa I just felt
like I had to fight that all White's
pieces are bad here and not really
risking much cuz that best for white
we're gonna give up the d4 pawn to trade
Queens and even that is probably around
equal mm-hmm didn't seem like there was
much risk yeah it seemed like okay your
your attack was coming pretty strong
very nice move Ponty three at what point
did you feel like the game was just
completely winning already here I think
already after thanks before it seemed
completely winning
well let's see how the game finished
given that not sure
Queenie six is the most accurate but I
was already a long time so I just went
for the most simple what now we weren't
looking at the time situation was he
also long time or he was meant for
grenades oh wow so yeah sometimes it's
nerve-racking having the better position
but having the time deficit you want to
be careful not to slip up but seemed
like a very smooth position to play just
moves came in pretty naturally when the
e3 pawn and yeah Queen e2 nice move
lying h2 and Wow 95 yeah beautiful
finish given and then this for given
that the queen is tied down to both
rooks and your Bishop plays a role by
pinning upon so what are your thoughts
going forward in the tournament are you
are you just taking it one game at a
time do you prepare for each opponent
beforehand I'm doing it mostly late the
night before the morning of I just
looked at their games briefly before the
tournament but most of their preparation
is right before the game gosh and you
know who you're playing tomorrow I think
I have white against this hole right
yeah
against Holtz okay and now you're not
only going for a potential Norum but
you're also fighting for the lead in
your group what is it like being kind of
an underdog going into the event I mean
you're one of two non geun's who are
playing in the vent are you do you feel
perhaps a lack of confidence going into
the vent or do you feel like you're
you're able to maintain your confidence
and your form against these strong
players I feel like it wasn't really
thinking too much about confidence it
just in my last few tournaments I've
gone down like 60 points all because of
time trouble so I'm trying to fix that
problem is for me
okay well I won't keep you any longer
best of luck in your next games and we
are going to take a quick commercial
break we'll be back with more coverage
from the 2018 fall just classic
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because white
masters pawn to square is not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
can't say play King in seven games you
too and now try because y'all played
four against Lawrence and now he's going
to play something against me which we
discussed the playing there during the
course of my stay
yeah he told me this is that fun g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think the farthest I know
who Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
and your visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game heading back
to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Loup is always
exploring and hello welcome back to
round five coverage of the 2018 fall
chess classic Ben Simon with
international master Eric Rosen
Brandon Jacobson was just in the studio
and he says look I can't help it I can't
stop thinking about the norm
opportunities here you know and I so
many players that you hear from they say
oh I'm just gonna take it one game at a
time but I really like that answer from
Brandon I did too yeah I mean you have
to at this level you have to have some
mental discipline you can't worry about
the external factors whether it be norms
prize money fame and glory affecting
your play you just have to focus on
playing good moves while we were away
ray Robson has defeated sefferman in
Group A and with just a royal pin I
guess you could call it there at the end
huh royal pin Bishop pinning the Queen
to the king
beautiful well let's see if we can get
that position up on the board here there
we go there we go
very impressive play by Ray I know he
was a bit low on time but we saw this
move knife f5 earlier and this final
position Bishop to d4 taking advantage
of the fact that this rook on d8 is
overworked it's defending the f8 square
and Ewa takes on d4 there the Queen f8
mates otherwise Bach is just losing a
queen it would be great if we could get
ray in the studio to talk about this is
first winner in the tournament I think
it might be this brings him back up to
an even score yes he had three drawers
and
a lost - coos above actually a third
round against Lenderman he came down
here for an interview both players did
and they were like actually really
excited to talk with us but the show had
already gone off the air so yeah we
should really talk to Ray if possible
because I know he has a lot he wants to
share just have to make sure the studio
door isn't isn't locked nothing in
trying to get in right right right
so yeah we'll we'll work on that so
there's only one game left in Group A
Darrell spirits versus Eric Hansen is
still in progress but all the other
games have finished Cuza bob has
defeated hammer riot we were expecting
that game yeah for the the hammer - got
hammered and in this case pretty tough
finish as White's pieces did crash
through actually really like the finish
look at the Queen and rook playing a
very brutal role against attacking the
black King and you may think that light
just won the Queen and won the game but
the game ended without white actually
capturing the black Queen after Bishop
f6 a very nice move rather than taking
on g6 Queen h8 check taking advantage of
the pinned bishop on f6 and getting
ready to take the bishop with the Queen
on that six and then white is just
cruising to victory is there I yes I
mean Queen take f6 King to h7 any time I
could just take the Queen winning we
could have some fun and try and keep
checking around and maybe over key eight
doesn't quite lead to anything mate
would be inevitable though after rooks
86
Wow that tournament hall has emptied out
in a hurry look at that wide shot right
there yeah lots of empty boards that's
the only game right there you see dark
spirits and err cants and that's the
only one still in progress in Group A
and Group A yes and that's gonna be a
long fight the position we saw earlier
with Eric just turtling up on the Kings
side he's managed to trade off the pair
of knights and now it's it's a bit
easier to breathe but this okay this
work on each seven still very much out
of play and what is still having most of
the fun but it is a question how to
break through and I'm wondering in this
position they're unmoved 39 after Queen
to c7 just played I'm wondering if daro
is considering a potential Bishop
sacrifice bishop take g6 looks very
enticing sacking the bishop for two
pawns but opening up the G file for this
rook battery but I'm not sure if it's
something to go for when you have 30
seconds left it calculates he did not
play what did he play
looks like he played something move he
played Queens e4 much more controlled
move this gives him an additional half
hour on the clock
and now Hanson is left thinking here he
has one more move to play until he
reaches move 40 and he has less than a
minute to to play his next move so
should stay on this moment until he
makes his next move not sure if that we
can determine what the time is the DDT
digital board says just over 40 seconds
time see the Red Bull by his side sure
you might need that energy boost going
into the the next phase of this game
where you will hopefully get the extra
half hour okay just just about 20
seconds left okay plays King to e8 we
can take a closer look at this game
while we wait for Darrow's next move
really your choice but we do have Ray
wraps and outside the studio ready for
an interview so we'll get him set up
okay well sounds good yeah we could all
go around the games here and see what is
what is going on maybe we can go back to
this game between Alshon more idea body
and ox ondra they have a very
interesting endgame where black is up
the exchange
well white has three pawns for it four
pawns against one pawn if you just count
the funds this seems like a very nice
situation for like to be in a lot of
time for both players last move that was
played white actually snagged a pawn
with Rick to g6 check rook take g5 it's
gonna be tough for a black to hold on
here given that these King side pawns on
g2 and h3 are passed pawns white is
gonna have have a lot of time
potentially regroup and keep things
defended and perhaps slowly make
progress trying to predict what black
will do here if doc ever tries to get
counter play with a move like let's say
rook EE to white can very easily defend
perhaps even 95 and if King f6 there
would be Knight f3 just holding on
making sure that g2 is constantly
defended and if rook F - there's always
rook g3 and as long as Y can keep
everything held together then eventually
like can start making progress
so my money is on Alshon here to
eventually win the game but we could see
a very long fight in this one
now I do want to go back to the game
that has just completed and welcome
grandmaster ray raphson in the studio
ray I do have to compliment you on your
jacket
having having had it from the Olympia in
Batumi I first want to ask how have you
been recovering from from coming back
overseas not amazingly well
I feel relatively okay it's just that
obviously I'm still I was tired after
the event and then even though I didn't
play that much but I was still preparing
and stuff and I don't know I just
haven't been able to sleep as much as I
wanted to so that's the one thing which
I wish I could do better but just hasn't
been happen do you feel like the start
was kind of slow due to the kind of the
nature that okay you have to come over
jet lag and you have to just play an
event after arriving and then do you
feel maybe some momentum after this game
I guess there's always momentum after
you win but no I didn't feel like I
wasn't expecting to start very fast the
only thing that was annoying was
obviously that I lost with with white
and I just I was - I want to win that
game probably too much and I just took
really bad decision but that was my only
white game before this game and all my
other three games always black and all
the players here are very very strong
and I didn't have any chances really to
win any of those games so I didn't
really expect to have like lots of
chances either so obviously I'm trying
to press with my white game so I tried
to push for this game I played the
English opening which which I wanted to
ask about because you're you're
notorious for playing yeah before I move
on when was the last time you played the
English opening if ever I I don't know
that I've ever played c4 and move on
I've played d4 and I played Knight f3
and transpose to English
a few times but I don't think I ever
started with c4 because obviously black
can play e5 which he he did and it's
true it's not like I have a lot of
analysis on the English I just decided
to play it like last night I just know
just last night I just thought it would
be a good choice but the thing is he
plays almost every line against it so I
had a lot to look at and so obviously I
couldn't prepare super deeply in every
single line well it's nice to catch them
maybe a little bit off guard I'm sure he
was preparing maybe more yeah sure do
you think being no I know you play
sicilians black that's being a Sicilian
player help with plain English there
could be some reverse Sicilians honestly
I'm really terrible at the reverse
positions like I don't even recognize
that when positions are reversed colors
that that they are a reverse position
and I feel like with the Sicilian it's
more dynamic I mean the English is
surprisingly dynamic and in these lines
but it's still more positional I feel
like so it does have a different feel to
it well take us through the game because
it seemed like somewhat of a quiet
opening and then at some point the
fireworks started I didn't I knew this
was a line I think g3 is a mover at
least that's the plan
Bishop g2 and blacks trying to play f5
that's what he was trying to do that's
why I played an h4 cuz if I had played
Bishop g2 immediately I thought maybe he
could play maybe Knight b6 first and
then the same d3 than f5 so I just
wanted to play in that h4 first to make
sure he couldn't get an f5 too quickly
and of course later ideas were playing
Knight f5 which you yeah that you could
play and then a6 was first really
interesting moment and it I wasn't sure
what to think about I mean when he first
played I didn't think it was a good move
but
I still feel like it shouldn't be that
good but I wasn't able to find a real
reputation so the tomb was I thought
about her castle rd3 yeah castle makes
the most sense probably but then after
b5 here I was thinking a lot about d4
take-take-take and by the way I didn't
take on b5 first and then d4 because in
some ways he'd have Roque for protecting
his night hunt before so here's
something like I can play Queen B - or
Queen d2 that's like Queen d2 looks most
natural and here I think he has to play
96 if he plays something like one of the
Knights to e6 then I hope I have for f5
very quickly and then f6 so nice e6 and
I have e5 if I want and then he just
plays Bishop d7 and somehow here yeah it
looked very tempting at first but then I
didn't feel like there was really
anything and now his night isn't pinned
anymore he couldn't take on e5 next move
because c5 Knight protects the bishop so
I'll have to take and then I think you
should be fine so I really wanted to
play d4 but then I just couldn't make it
work so instead I took on b5 and I'd
work at d1 so I'm still trying to play
d4 and then I was anticipating at this
annoying okay four move but otherwise he
can't really stop deforested Lee and now
I'd really like to play Bishop b2 to
again tidy for but then before I think
is working d4 b takes c3 d c5 c b2 and
his work on a for thinking but my rook
on any one is hanging and so he should
be fine
so unfortunately I didn't find anything
better than playing d3 which was a lot
slower than I wanted it to be but I just
didn't see what other move I had so he
played Bishop e6 Bishop e3 this all
looks critical Queenie yeah otherwise I
mean d4 was coming so he has this
Queenie a move which prepares both pins
the apron so he has ideas of might be
through Bishop you through him and he's
just attacking the pawn so so d4 looks
for us that's all kind of looked I'm
critical and then actually was surprised
by Knight e3 I was looking at edie for
mostly but maybe it wasn't the best
nobody
if 84 CD 4 and now one line for instance
is like b3 and I was thinking parley I
can just play d5 here Knight a one okay
one i'm forking him but here's night
before but now I take c7 and the next
move
well actually the Bishop isn't in a
great spot at Bishop g4 I might play h3
first and yeah I'm taking d6 and well
it's tricky let's say Bishop g4 let's
just cook c8 Queen d6 92 he could try
something like that but I thought if I
just take g4 and might take some I know
probably tonight at 5 or something my
pieces look so so did you actually
calculate the scienter here oh well so I
know you like to spend your time
calculating Oh wrong was I spent way too
much time after he played a6 the next
like 2 moves because I was calculating a
lot of stuff and I wasn't sure and I
didn't find anything that clearly gave
me advantage which I felt like should be
there so that was really enough for a 6
on move yeah do you remember how long
you spent at this moment I spent a
really long time and then also after b5
I thought again because I wanted to play
d4 but then I realized that I wasn't
really
working as far as I could see so so then
after I play d4 I move sixteen might be
three yeah
so his idea is just I'm gonna be able to
play d5 and he's gonna take a one or are
you gonna get one of my rooks and I'll
get two pieces which actually seems
pleasant for whites me I don't know good
night before I go so I could have played
d5 immediately instead of a takes b3 I
could play d5 here 981 or okay one and
here I keep the pair of rooks but I
think I want to have on the board I
think but my pawn structure is worse
because now my AG pawn is isolated and
in the game we got to be three so
something like Bishop d7 d c6 Bishop c6
I guess f3 and I wasn't sure but maybe
maybe it was better than what happened
because in the game maybe I was worse
I'm not sure yeah I still seem very
complex he's gonna be running Bishop g4
to force me to play F 3 instead of
Bishop d7 but I also protect the e4 pawn
so he went to play Bishop d7 and takes
c6 so that's why he did it this way and
then I actually played after myself so I
just didn't find anything better he's
starting to take D 1 and e 4 here well
here I had very little time and I had to
make 20 more moves and his position
might also be better his I mean normally
2 pieces for the rook and pawn is is
really good but he has a great structure
here and once you get into endgame it's
not so clear with the 2 pieces first
that's very true it seemed like the
position opened up a lot after d5 yeah I
was happy that it opened up because then
my pieces gun I didn't think D if I was
actually a good move
then he weakened his whole pawn
structure and also like my fish
got c5 so do you think the fact that you
were low on time maybe provokes him to
be over ambitious and play a bit riskier
I think mmm
that happens sometimes yeah maybe look
somewhat and maybe he wants to play d5
because it makes the game more sharp it
looks like it makes the game more sharp
and obviously I had little time thought
I also think he just thought he was
better I see he was now I only get to
this moment where you play this very
surprising move Knight f5 which caught
caught us I've got off guard in the
studio given that it's not the type of
move that you would normally consider
this a move that you would you saw from
afar or yeah do you think do you think
he was expecting it to work oh I don't
think he was expecting that f5 here I
would have liked to play like I saw this
thing is he has such weak dark squares
no since you played g6 which maybe I
don't know if g6 was the best because ya
know he has all these weak squares and I
wouldn't to play I would like to play
Queen d2 instead instead of Knight f5
and then have take let's say Knight f5
now but it's too slow with because he
has Bishop c4 so the idea of 905 is that
if he takes on f5 then I play Queen d2
now and then I tacked the bishop and
then I also going to g5 where I at least
have a perpetual and probably if that if
he just takes f3 I don't think I have
more because let's say check and King h8
let's say if I tried Bishop d7 or
something then here with his queen e7
and then
oh it's a it's a do or die move yeah so
I could I mean I could check on have six
and said and take f5 but it's probably
still just it's probably draw oh yeah I
don't know should be a job take out a
second take f5 and then Queen c3 and now
yeah I think it's just a draw because I
still don't have Bishop to e7 you would
really love to play this but yeah
because he this diagonal yeah but I
think I mean he was still trying to win
but he was also getting lower on time
and like for the first time after he
took on f3 and I played Queen d2 like I
felt like I'm actually can can actually
try to win or I could actually win the
game because um I I mean he could take
i-5 still it transposes to the previous
line but it didn't feel like he was
about to take half I felt like he was
still maybe trying to weigh and or
didn't sense how much danger there was
right I mean I couldn't I I were playing
this position as black I I might easily
see the Queen g5 King eh it and then not
see Queen a7 after Bishop e7 given that
it so much focuses on the King side you
could forget about the his long distance
moves with the Queen so yeah maybe yeah
like Queen a6 um so his he's just
bringing the Queen back to the defense
but the problem is now I have Queen age
six and he can't take five because
there's this funny pin so he has to play
Queen f6 and at first
um when I was thinking after Queen d2
and it was his turn like at first I
thought that this would be fine for him
that probably I should shouldn't provoke
his Queen to f6 but then I realized that
if I just protect the night so I played
Bishop d3 now he still can't say cuz he
still pinned and I'm turning Bishop d7
which would force Queen h8 which
has to be losing that looks like a dream
come true for whites he loved to play
efore but the problem is he just never
can because I have Bishop d4 so it's a
box was stuck here
I'm just hurting Bishop II something
he's just stuck so first like the main
thing I thought about here was rook a a
because he still does have these Queen
like check ideas if I move the bishop
from c5 so here if Bishop d7 he'd have
Queen b6 check then if came to foreigner
okay one is meeting me
so after rook e8 the other thing is his
rook is also stuck because if it leaves
the back rank i have queen of faith mate
so here i can't anything so here I was
planning to just play h3 because I was
thinking about something that King F -
but he had Bishop g4 probably so just I
don't know h3 just seemed like a useful
move and I didn't see what what he could
do here I mean he could still I don't
know what I'm threatening maybe King f2
but I just didn't see what move yeah he
was making so I thought it's very at
least you got a position where you can
maybe play Ted more boots and make make
move 40 also I just I mean looks very
hard for him to defend because he also
didn't have time objectively it might
even just be like very bad is there some
plan maybe like chief 45 years well I
was saying maybe King f2 next move
so also like where where can he go it's
almost a song we chose sure that's true
yeah I think can you pick running h8 now
he wants to keep the rope on the
uh-huh you can play King h8 and then
King f2
bishop somewhere and now
I still say still thinkin I just buy g4
no no turning g5 no well as king is
controlling or maybe after King HT maybe
even g4 immediately and then g5 is the
idea
maybe that's the main idea of a giant h3
and the king has to go back to G hits
then g5 Queen 1897 I'll be a nice finish
this seemed like a very aesthetic attack
starting with 9f5 where once you get to
the situation where the queen is pinning
the pawns seems like things are just
going in your favor
yeah so he played rook e8 and now I saw
I thought I could just take the pawn um
and basically just go back at least cuz
again he's still stuck and he can't take
again because Queen of fate and the one
thing is it does look like he might have
efore here because if Bishop d4 his rook
takes d4 now because his real cause of
the default but I had noticed this trick
and well obviously I was hoping he'd
fall for it but yeah and he actually did
because I have this 97 first and then
fortunately if you should be for works
because I have two made on that fate
yeah beautiful finish this is I think
one of the nicer attacking games so far
this tournament there have been a lot
like law games ending and like these
solid drawers or endgame grinds but we
haven't seen too many like devastating
attacking games like this so far so that
puts you back in and even score on what
are your thoughts going forward with the
rest of the games you're just gonna take
it one game at a time or yeah well I I
didn't really look at pairings like
ahead of time so you know yeah I don't
know who I'm playing the only thing I
knew before the tournament started
before I check the pairings was that I
was playing Alex Linderman in round 3
with black because he's all like he was
also in part of the US team but you guys
work together yeah so he told me that we
were playing around three well yeah it's
going to be tough like I only have two
more white games and
playing I mean everyone's strong but I
think I'm things really sold people I
forget who but and yeah I also I don't
think like I'm playing amazingly well so
you know I just want to be solid and and
try to have as much energy so that I can
try to play a little faster because like
I really had to make so many moves today
a long time and somehow like I was able
to but it usually could have gone badly
for me yeah sometimes it's just a matter
of discipline well I won't keep you any
longer best of luck in your next rounds
and get some rest
Thanks so we are going to take a look
back at the games I believe there's been
a few results I want to go back to the L
Shaun more dia body against Aakash
Andhra game because L Shaun has finally
got his pawn rolling on the kingside
pawn is now on h5 within range of
queening and black is struggling to come
up with any sort of counter play we can
see time situation for Akshat they're
well past move 40 and okay Oxshott has
just over five minutes to make the rest
of his moves we should keep in mind the
30-second increments is in effect but
okay not acid a great situation for
black to be in I do want to welcome back
to the studio and Simon good to have you
back do you have any update Sonny any
more results well we have three games
total still happening and we do know
that in Group B the gabbu Xion is on his
way
cruisin to yet another victory Wow and
so this will keep him we saw Jacobsen
win today so it's still he's still just
gonna be one point ahead of the pack but
this guy is unstoppable I got and in
this round against Conrad hold with the
black pieces it looks like it's really
breaking down here what's your
assessment of the situation this is this
is shocking given that I dismiss this as
a draw at the beginning of the broadcast
thinking that's okay Conrad was up upon
I want to go back to that moment where I
thought it was just gonna end in a draw
very shortly I was thinking that white
might be the one trying to win having
extra pawn but yeah in hindsight I'm
realizing that if black can win back one
pawn given that all of White's pawns are
weak the black will naturally have a
better structure and it seems like
that's exactly what happened there have
been even soli moves I've been played in
this endgame black did go up upon with
Knight take f4 and then black proceeded
to win the pawn eventually on d4 and
then there was just a three-on-two
endgame lots of dancing around here
white took on f4 but looks like there
was no defense to this H pawn and then
okay
she curious around this moment why this
move Knight th war wasn't played but now
I'm realizing Knight 86
so go Busey and clearly trying to keep
all the tension in the position if if my
Tiki six here why was that not played
he's 700k the rook was attacked so
there's no time for night Tiki six due
to King at six given that both pieces
would be attacked let's zoom forward to
the current position because this is
just a two-on-one battle with rooks and
knights still on the board and go Busey
and has these two connected passed pawns
pretty well placed in the center now
it's a question if he can he can convert
the damage I really like his time
situation still over an hour on the
clock which is very surprising
surprising given that we're over four
hours into the first round yeah it is
unusual okay so we've covered the two
remaining games in Group B a group a we
still have daro versus Eric Hansen we
are approaching the end of our time with
all of you though so we want to remind
you to join us for the rest of the
rounds every day at 3:30 p.m. Central
Time we're starting earlier on the last
day which is Thursday and you can watch
the game
at us chest champs calm and you can
watch them beginning at 1 p.m. Central
Time every day we'll just come on two
and a half hours after the start of the
program so this show was produced by the
world's greatest production B team
Tammy Hyde is the streamer Isaac Krantz
is our graphics and audio man and our
technical director is Danny Machuca my
name is Ben Simon I'm Eric Rosen and we
will see you tomorrow until then so long
from the Show Me State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you